Please welcome John Eringman.
(audience applauding)
Hello.
I'm super excited to be here
and share some tips with you guys,
some actionable tips and all that.
I mean, it's been such a journey.
I really enjoy this stuff. It's my passion.
All right, so the topic of money
can be very intimidating.
What sparked your interest?
Yeah, so growing up,
we never really talked about money in our household,
and that's like millions of other people.
We don't talk about money because it's a taboo subject.
And so that was kind of the narrative that I grew up with
is like we don't talk about money
with other people, you know?
And so that's kind of what sparked my interest
in that curiosity of money,
and that's why I start to encourage people
to talk about money
because if we don't have these uncomfortable conversations,
then we're never gonna learn about money.
And if we never learn about money,
then we're not gonna make informed financial decisions
about our money.
And if we don't make informed financial decisions,
we're gonna end up in debt like the video showed.
So you need to talk and have that conversation
with friends and family members.
So how did you become a full-time financial influencer?
Yeah, well, I went to the University of Cincinnati.
I graduated with a finance degree in 2018
and became a financial accountant.
And because I was having
these uncomfortable conversations with people,
these money conversations,
people started coming to me more and more
asking the same questions over and over.
And so I was like
"Instead of answering the same question,
why don't I just make some videos about it?"
And at the time in 2019,
TikTok was starting to gain some traction,
and it just slowly kept taking off.
And so now, I quit my job,
I'm a full-time finfluencer now
is what they call it, financial influencer.
(audience applauding)
And it's just given me so many opportunities
to talk to people and to come on your show, Drew,
so it's just been amazing.
(bright music)